hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's edition of what I
eat in a day you to refuse is sponsored
by native and I'm to be looking at
controversial muck banger and cheating
enthusiast Livia Adams from the YouTube
channel always hungry now of course I
want a flag yes I sound a little
congested because a couple days ago my
kid gave me a cold and I'm over it now
but of course I'm dealing with this sexy
voice aftermath so bear with me here
also I want to chat about this natural
deodorant I've been using from native
I've always been pretty picky about my
skin care products but this is
particularly true while pregnant and
since my first pregnancy I've been on
the hunt for a natural deodorant that
actually works even after a workout or a
really long day so they sent me the
coconut vanilla cucumber mint and
lavender rose cents my favorite being
the vanilla of course but I've been
using them for the past few weeks and
guess what I actually smell really nice
so this theater isn't sticky it dries
fast they have a bunch of yummy scents
and they're vegan plus also aluminum
paraben and sulfate free and they're
packed with natural ingredients like
coconut oil and shea butter so you can
visit the link below and use the code a
b24 33% off your first native deodorant
pack plus free shipping okay folks now
let's hop into the meat of this video
beginning with my general disclaimer
that the information in this video is
for entertainment and educational
purposes only and you should always seek
out the help of a registered dietitian
or a medical professional for your
unique case I also want to note that
today's videos may be triggering for any
of my followers who are currently or
have previously struggled with
disordered eating or an eating disorder
so please feel free to skip this video
if you're unsure I also want to remind
you please let's keep the comments clean
I want to keep this space respectful and
supportive so if you are going over to
always Hungry's channel or you're
leaving comments below please nothing
personal I want to keep it supportive
now if you've ever watched any videos
from always hungry you'll know that
libya is known for her over-the-top
cheat day videos and food challenges she
is also be
very open and honest on her channel
about her recovery from anorexia and
claims that her cheat days have really
been an important way for her to
overcome her fear of food and become
more flexible with eating now the whole
cheat day concept is not new but it has
definitely become popularized by the
fitness community as a type of kind of
rewards based diet strategy that allows
for a brief period of indulgence about
once a week or so usually it involves
following a highly restrictive and
controlled diet for about six days a
week and then on the seventh day you'll
cheat on your diet by consuming
high-calorie foods that are often
restricted throughout the week now I'm
gonna be talking a lot more about my
thoughts on cheat days later on in this
video
but Livia takes her cheetah videos to an
extreme by bringing them into kind of
the mukbang or eating challenged
territory now I've already shared my
thoughts on the MOOC bang trend on the
channel before so you can definitely
check that out here but for those of you
who are unfamiliar with milk bang in
Western culture at least it's now become
an over-the-top eating challenge that
involves eating large quantities of food
in a very short period of time in front
of an audience
aka YouTube all of you so to start off I
want to get a sense of what Livia eats
on a regular day when she's not over
indulging on a cheat day
let's meet Libya I just show you how is
I'll put a little disclaimer right here
that this is not how everybody should
eat this is not how I eat every single
day it's just today what I eat I try to
stay between 1400 1600 calories i
roughly track all track today so you
know what kind of calories are consumed
usually I just go by hungriness
but sometimes just to make sure I'll
track roughly to see that
so in libyans disclaimer I like that
she's being upfront about not promoting
a specific type of diet or way of eating
and that she generally eats based on her
hunger signals which may look different
day to day I am very much on board with
this type of approach as we really
should all be tuning into our bodies and
following our hunger and satiety cues
and it's true I mean if we intuitively
follow our hunger signals what and how
much we eat may look different day to
day however Olivia does say that she
will Sun eyes track her calories to make
sure she's within the 1400 to 1600
calorie range now I will say this range
would be considered quite low for a
woman
Livius age and activity level in general
a healthy diet for someone like Livia
would be somewhere between 1,800 and
2200 calories so even though she does
say she follows her hunger signals this
calorie range says she aims towards does
sound a bit restrictive to me let's see
what's next with me these are popsicle
brands they taste like wesbar are low
carbs 21 grams of protein and 16 grams
of fiber for me because we never have
breakfast or lunch now I am all about
convenience and really the easier you
can make meal prepping the better
however what I am NOT a huge fan of is
the idea of skipping meals you know
right before you're going to work out
specifically but just in general I mean
that is a recipe for disaster
so not only will this not optimize the
time that you spend in the gym but it
may set you up for a late-night binge
session I mean both breakfast and lunch
on just a hundred and ninety calories
that is not enough if you are in a rush
having a meal before a workout can
really be as easy as spreading a
tablespoon of peanut butter on some
toast with some fruit on top or whipping
up some omie with berries or even
opening up a can of tuna
to have some crackers and veggies
I mean convenience in my books is no
justification to skipping a meal if you
have time to make a youtube video about
it you probably have time to put
something in your mouth now I know Libya
has four protein bars at the ready to
feel her workout and recovery however in
this case the energy and macronutrient
profile that she's getting from these
bars is really just not sufficient for
this kind of workout ideally a
pre-workout snack should really focus on
those carbohydrates to give you the
energy to fuel your workout and then
your post-workout snack should really be
focusing on the combination of
carbohydrates and protein now in general
the ideal ratio for a post-workout snack
in particular would be one gram of
protein for every two to four grams of
carbs also the amount of fiber in these
bars is just going to slow down the rate
of digestion and pre-workout that's not
ideal cuz it could give you cramps and
post-workout you know you want your
muscle cells to be fed as soon as
possible now this would be great if
maybe you want to pair it with some
fruit for some extra carbs but all on
its own it's still sounding a little
restrictive to me let's take a look at
next snack okay I do want to pause here
for a second because I don't think I've
ever witnessed somebody drink almond
milk by the glass but girl if you're
enjoying it you do you but let's just
talk about the nutrition there I mean
not a whole lot coming from almond milk
but a great source of protein I am
seeing protein kind of being the theme
of the day so far there's not a lot of
carbs let's see what's next
food is ready I have myself you saw what
I put on end up also going to put come
to a sauce on it
it's from it's not very good by the way
these are a live pack chopped onions are
so crispy and they make every dish
better also this is what my cauliflower
turkey rice looks like I also go I'm
also going to have one or two of these
and yeah this is what I cooked for Nate
this is Kylie
this is Turkey onions peppers and Kino
our rice so we have that uh so yeah I'm
I'm happy to finally see Libya prepare a
real meal for herself
her meal she's got some ground turkey
salsa cauliflower rice and she uses it
as like a tortilla filling sounds pretty
yummy very simple it's relatively
balanced totally something I would be
down for him however the portion size of
this meal is really concerning the
amount of filling in this bowl looks to
me like it would equal about three to
four servings on top of that she also
has a whole bag of lettuce with a
totally fat-free dressing sugar free
dressing made with sugar free pancake
syrup and some white vinegar really not
a whole lot going on there I'm honestly
not entirely surprised that Libya has a
bigger appetite at this point in the day
and is able to consume this larger
quantity of food considering she really
has only had a few snacks during the day
while also having a full-blown workout
at the gym personally I would like to
have seen Libya space out her caloric
and taken protein throughout the day a
little bit better and that would help
regulate her appetite and avoid any dips
and spikes in blood sugar levels and
also better support her workout recovery
as well by simply adding in a
substantial breakfast and line
with some snacks in between if needed
perhaps her dinner meal wouldn't need to
be large enough to feed a whole family
okay let me tell you my overall thoughts
on this what I eat in a day overall I
like that Libya says that she relies on
her hunger signals to guide her eating
however like a lot of these youtubers I
feel that they don't always walk the
talk aiming towards a caloric
restriction does seem to contradict this
approach and would interfere with her
ability to intuitively follow her body's
needs I would have also liked to see
Libya spent less time preparing separate
meals for her and her partners that her
meal could be lower calories and more
time into preparing bounced meals for
breakfast and lunch it would also be
great to see a little bit more nutrition
around her workout and also spacing her
calories at war evenly throughout the
day I also have to just say that the
substantial load of calories at the end
of the day is a classic restrictive
mentality symptom a lot of dieters who
restrict heavily all day long end up
spending all of their calories in huge
meals at the end of the night it's kind
of like let's save these calories for
later thing that is basically an
extension of the restrict our week binge
on a cheat day mentality we will get
more into this later but I also want to
really just point out but even if the
total calories for the day look okay the
way that they're eaten may not be ideal
now let's move on to the real issue
Livia's cheat date videos now the
majority of Libya's videos are pretty
outrageous and over the top some
examples of her videos include eating as
many doughnuts as possible in one day
eating the entire alphabet eating
anywhere between 10,000 and 15,000
calories eating everything from Pizza
Hut
you get the gist her videos are
basically cheat day on steroids in that
even if there was a benefit to a cheat
day metabolically any nutrition expert
would say that this strategy would
completely undermine it as for today's
video we're gonna specifically Zone in
on her anorexia versus 10k calorie
talyn's to get a sense of how Libya's
eating disorder history plays into her
cheat days also before we do another
reminder that what you're about to
the may be triggering for some of you
and also that my commentary here is
really not meant to be mean-spirited
it's ultimately meant to give you all
some insight into some of these common
problematic behaviors that we see here
on YouTube let's take a look many of you
guys probably tell us with food in the
past I was suffering from eating this
way and 2017 was actually making me free
when I had my first cheat day in April
and I was always contemplating when
doing the 10k challenge never dare to
because I want to trigger myself but I
feel like it's time to show you guys
that numbers don't matter that much and
this is obviously disclaimer I don't
recommend you to have a goal to hit 10k
on your cheat day long or it is just for
entertainment purposes and also to show
you guys that weight it's not everything
and from touch time it's important to
enjoy yourself
so yeah I will have the whole day to get
my 10k gold also what I what I didn't
want to do is I didn't want to calculate
everything while I'm eating it just to
make it more enjoyable for myself I have
a roughly count in my head but only my
editing self will know if I actually hit
10k but I hope you guys doing
this is for you guys out there or
suffering from a fear of food and I want
to make you comfortable with it I want
to show you enjoy yourself it doesn't
really matter at the end of the day
obviously you should do that every
single day and you should be healthy
most of the time but coming from a place
where I took healthy to have it level
and everything that was enjoyable
regarding food I can't say that you
should definitely definitely definitely
make food your friend and enjoy yourself
so I really appreciate libya's
vulnerability here and that she's being
so open and honest with her followers
about her recovery from an eating
disorder it really sounds like she's in
a better mindset when it comes to eating
because she emphasizes the importance of
creating a pleasurable relationship with
food and enjoying yourself
she also empowers her viewers to not
worry about weight or numbers and she
also mentions that she's not going to be
really counting the calories religiously
while she's eating in order to make the
eating experience more enjoyable for her
all around
I like the messaging here and I'm happy
to see Lidia describing herself as being
in a better place mentally when it comes
to her eating as for her rationale for
doing the 10k calorie talyn's olivia
claims she's doing this as a way to free
herself completely of numbers and fear
of waking research has shown that
exposure to challenging foods as a means
to face one's fear is an effective
therapeutic method for normalizing foods
to make them feel safe or less scary or
forbidden so I totally praise Libya for
her commitment to free herself from
numbers and challenging herself to face
her fears through food exposure however
I do not totally agree with the method
in which she's doing it I know the 10k
calories is a new trendy YouTube tag but
for somebody with an eating disorder
history like Olivia this type of eating
challenge has the potential to be very
triggering and perpetuate the cycle of
restriction and binging now I know that
Libya seems to be in a better mindset
when it comes to eating and has made
some significant strides in her
disorder recovery but I am concerned
about the message that descends to her
followers who may also be struggling
with eating disorders or disordered
eating so before we go to discuss this
further let's go ahead and see how Livia
does during the 10k calorie town a--make
you watch any more of that but first we
see Olivia starting her 10k calories by
drinking five glasses of white chocolate
milk and by this point she's already
reached about half her daily energy
requirement from liquids alone so yeah
let's see what's to come this is roughly
500 calories okay so I'm not gonna watch
her go through all of that but not only
did Olivia have a crispy chicken
sandwich but she also managed to eat
nothing donuts 9 now I am a huge
doughnut junkie but even in my pregnant
state and now having to eat for two I
would never be able to eat nine donuts
in one sitting without feeling really
unwell overly stuffed and way past the
point of fullness
like I love donuts they are my favorite
treat of all time and they wouldn't even
taste good at that point so I'm starting
to get really nervous to see what Livia
has in store for us next
[Music]
so this is crazy
I mean Livia has created this like pizza
burger concoction where she's got two
mini pizzas wrapped in dough that she
uses as the bun then she adds three
pounds of beef four strips of bacon
sauces and burger toppings this is like
something you'd see at the funfair I
mean kudos Olivia for coming up with
this very interesting and inventive
burger creation I mean I'm not gonna lie
if I saw a burger pizza on a menu
somewhere I would definitely consider
trying it just to see what was gonna
come out but again the quantity of food
that Livia has been able to consume at
this point in the challenge especially
in the context in comparison to what
she's eating on a normal regular day is
quite alarming let's see what's next
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so we have finally gone to the end
of Libya's 10k calorie Tallinn Jan I
don't know about you guys but I feel
like I have a full on food baby on top
of my real baby just from washing that
no but seriously there is a lot to
unpack here so I want to start by
talking about the risks of consuming
large quantities of food in one sitting
and the effects that this has on the
body now when we overeat or eat past the
point of fullness there are a series of
metabolic reactions that occur in the
body to assist with the digestion and
absorption of food starting with the
stomach overeating increases production
of hydrochloric acid which can travel up
the esophagus and cause acid reflux or
heartburn this is especially true we
consume foods that are really high in
fat which of course she definitely did
there's also an increased amount of
blood that is sent to the stomach and
the intestines to help with the
digestion of larger amounts of
this causes increased heart rate and
blood pressure to keep up with the
metabolic demands of trying to digest
this high amount of food now the stomach
will also stretch to accommodate the
food that was just ingested which then
pushes other nearby organs and can make
you feel really uncomfortable and gassy
I mean I think we've all been there we
finished up the last serving at the
buffet and we have no choice but to like
discreetly unbutton our pants when we
finish our meal there's no shame in that
but I think we can all agree with how
uncomfortable that feeling really is now
overeating also takes its toll on the
digestive system by putting increased
strain on the liver and pancreas as they
work harder to secrete enzymes to break
down food in the digestive tract so
blood sugar levels will also spike
causing an increase in insulin to help
your cells absorb the higher amounts of
glucose in your bloodstream
on top of that your intestines are
working so hard to digest this larger
quantity of food that it's using up tons
of energy to do so making you feel
lethargic sweaty and even dizzy
bottom line eating the large amount of
food that we see livia do in her video
would be extremely taxing on the body
and what ultimately make you feel like
complete crap now in terms of Olivia's
nutrition not only does she surpass her
10000 calorie goal but her protein fat
carbohydrate and sodium intakes are off
the charts her saturated fat alone is
twelve hundred forty five percent of her
daily needs this is not at all
surprising to me now I know Olivia only
does her cheat days maybe once a week
and she doesn't always necessarily aim
for ten thousand calories but there is
definitely a trend in the majority of
her cheating videos where she tries to
consume as much food as possible in a
short 12 hour window on that note I want
to talk a little bit about the science
behind cheat days and the motivators
behind why someone like Livia may
participate in them so the popular
theory behind having a weekly cheat day
in the dieting or fitness community is
that it may potentially improve
metabolic function by manipulating the
hunger hormone left
now leptin is the hormone that signals
to us when we're full and tells us to
stop eating so the idea behind cheat
days is that consuming higher calorie
foods for short periods will essentially
trick your metabolism into temporarily
producing more leptin meaning you'll
feel less hungry in the days following a
cheat day
however there's actually very little
research to support this theory some
research has shown that yes leptin
production does increase by as much as
30% after temporarily increasing caloric
intake however the effects only last for
about 24 hours meaning if you were to
have a cheat day you might have a lower
appetite for one day afterwards at best
for it returns back to normal levels on
the flip side a lot of people describe
feeling super hungry after a cheat day
particularly one that is really high in
refined carbs and sugar this is possibly
because refined carbs are digested
really quickly since they lack any fiber
to slow down digestion and now results
in rapid spikes in blood sugar then
higher amounts of insulin gets secreted
in response in order to quickly remove
sugar from the bloodstream which can
then lead to a sudden drop in blood
sugar the result your body signals to
your brain that you are now super hungry
again despite having just consumed a
massive feast maybe hours prior studies
have also shown that restricting
calories can actually cause leptin to
decline this means that if you were to
restrict during the week to accommodate
your cheat meals you will be so starving
by the time that you get your cheat day
you can't help but overeat there's also
the psychological toll that cheat days
can have as they tend to strip any joy
away from eating during the week cheat
days automatically become the one day of
the week where you allow yourself to
enjoy food and essentially go ham on
foods that you've previously restricted
in the remainder of the week this also
puts you in the Last Supper or
all-or-nothing mentality where you feel
the need to eat as much as possible and
way more than you normally would because
you know that you'll be restricting the
rest of the week it creates a scenario
where you overeat not because you
necessarily want to or because it tastes
good but because you know that it's the
only time you can
if we compare Livia's what a in a day
video to her cheat day videos we
definitely see this pattern of
restriction and last supper mentality
and overeating with that said I do want
to highlight a vlog on Livius channel
where she talks about how her perception
of cheat days has really evolved and she
days just saved my life no two days
really helped me to overcome this fear
of food and also deal with changes in my
body you know getting bloated and being
okay with that and consuming more
calories and being okay with that so two
days have been amazing for me they
helped me so much they helped me regain
my flexibility with food and not being
so obsessed with it too but to everybody
out there I want you to know that life
is a development so you develop as a
person and you grow you try to be the
best person you can be and things change
so for me I felt like I wanted to take
the next step for myself and find a new
balance for me I love doing cheetahs and
I will continue doing cheetahs however I
won't do them every week I'll do them
every 10 to 14 days and challenge myself
to be even more flexible during the week
because I don't know the information out
there but I can assure you if you do
weekly cheat days you do have to take
care of what you eat well to have this
balance you know to be able to over eat
and enjoy yourself in just one day and
then be really healthy on the other days
and I found that this lifestyle that was
great for me but it found I found it
hard to maintain
and weeks because also like I said I
have a lot of things going on I can talk
about yet yeah I wanted to I wanted to
experiment a little bit more with myself
I wanted to you know challenge still
thoughts in my head that's basically it
weren't always there but sometimes gave
me the excuse to you know eat really
clean and stay away from like bad foods
during the week because of my weekly
cheat days and now I want to lift this
up to the next level being able to do
cheat days and being flexible during the
time I do not have cheat days and when I
say flexible I mean even more and I feel
like also one thing that scared me to do
so was what you guys would think because
I know that people threat change so when
something changes people are more likely
to not like it and not longer support
you so I feared that most of you guys
would not stick around like I really
want to make more content for you guys
out there but I also have to develop and
progress as a person so again I love
Libya's honesty and vulnerability here
and she she seems truly grateful for all
the positive impact that she days have
really had on her ability to overcome
her fear food and become more flexible
with eating however she does sort of
imply that having a weekly cheat day
does put more pressure on her during the
week to eat super clean and avoid bad
foods this is what I see as the fatal
flaw of the cheat day you know it forces
you into these polar extreme ways of
eating you know super clean and
low-calorie and then over the top excess
neither of which
feel really good or intuitive it sounds
like Libya is coming to this conclusion
herself which is so amazing and I'm
really hoping that maybe this video here
alone will give her the little push and
inspiration that she needs to
incorporate some more flexibility all
week long so maybe that looks like
incorporating a few of her favorite
cheat day state
like the donut or you know that chicken
sandwich
throughout her week and not feeling the
need to incorporate them all into one
epic day now let's move on to answer
some basic questions about Libya's
dietary patterns now in general do I
think this way of eating is balanced I
mean starting with Libya's 10k calories
eat a video the answer is obviously not
not only does Libya's today go way
overboard on calories fat sugar and
sodium but the sheer quantity of food is
way beyond what the average person
really should be eating in one sitting
to put this into perspective the amount
of calories she consumed in one day is
equivalent to six days worth of her
caloric needs and as most cheat days
tend to be Libya's food choices were
very carb heavy and high in fat this is
not intuitive at all because I cannot
imagine this feeling good to anyone
as for Livius what a today we did see a
little bit more balance with her dinner
meal but it was still really low in fat
and it's also pretty much where all of
that balance ended instead we saw a lot
of deliberate meal skipping and meal
replacing with some tiny protein bars
and diet food snacks throughout the day
I mean her what I in a day definitely
left much to be desired and taken
together with the rest of her content
there is a clear pattern of restricting
and binging going on now are there any
problematic claims or assumptions made
by this channel after reviewing Libya's
videos I don't see her making any direct
diet or wellness claims to her audience
and really is instead more focused on
sharing what she eats and showing us her
day to day life Libya is also constantly
open and honest about her eating
disorder history and provides some
positive messaging around creating a
pleasurable relationship with food and
being weight neutral by not focusing on
the numbers I know it must not be easy
for Libya to talk about her eating
disorder so publicly so I really do
applaud her and respect her for being so
brave to share her story on her Channel
in reviewing her videos I was also happy
to see that I didn't pick up on any kind
of explicit diet talk or food rule
that she was imposing on her viewers
which I do really appreciate however her
behavior is not entirely reflective of
the food philosophy that she shares with
us and this may be because she may just
still be on her recovery journey I mean
I know that she emphasizes that cheat
days have been very helpful for her
recovery but the binge restrict cycle is
very clearly embedded in her day-to-day
life and we can see that so clearly on
her channel so although she doesn't
directly make any problematic claims
around food and eating and instead she
tries to verbally send the opposite
message to her viewers talking a lot
about food freedom and having fun on her
cheap days the behavior here may
actually be interpreted very differently
now I can fully understand that livia
may create content for entertainment
purposes and shock value but for
somebody who's watching who struggles
with their own relationship with food
they may see Livia glorify the act of
eating nine donuts or five slices of
french toast in one sitting and think
that this is totally normal eating
behavior that it's intuitive eating
behavior or even maybe healthy eating
behavior for those who struggle with
disorder thoughts they may get the
message that this is the only way to
find freedom with food when maybe having
a doughnut on a Monday and a fried
chicken sandwich on a Friday is a much
more intuitive approach or they may
watch Libya's normal eating day and see
her restrict meals all day have a
strenuous workout and then have an
overly large high volume low-fat meal at
the end of the day and think that this
is very healthy and normal as well these
can be really harmful eating behaviors
and practices that further perpetuate
disordered eating and can further
entrench someone in the cycle of harmful
dieting behaviors ever someone like
Livia who's recovering from an eating
disorder I would have thought that maybe
should be a little bit more sensitive to
how her content may be interpreted by
someone who's struggling with
restriction or feeling out of control
with food and I know Livia has never
come out and said that you know this is
what you should do to recover from your
eating disorder but for vulnerable
viewer
if you're putting yourself out there as
an influencer people are going to follow
your lead and we have a huge
responsibility here now bottom line
even though cheat days have been
apparently an effective strategy for
Libya and combating for eating a sort of
thoughts like I said this method of
eating sort of recovery may actually do
more harm than good and and it does so
by perpetuating the good food versus bad
food mentality throughout the week
Lydia's cheat meals also have the
potential to be highly triggering for
some people and may actually exacerbate
eating related issues for individuals
dealing with disordered eating food
addiction emotional eating or just a
general inability to self-regulate their
eating habits
although Olivia seems to be evolving in
our approach to cheat meals and finding
flexibility with food which is so
amazing the current pattern of binging
and restriction is very evident right
now and of course it is a bit of a red
flag to me that this perhaps may be an
evolved form of her eating disorder now
I am NOT trying to diagnose Olivia or
discredit her recovery but it's actually
not uncommon to see eating disorders
evolve and interchange with other types
of compensatory eating behaviors through
my own personal experience I can totally
empathize with just how difficult it is
to free yourself from the grips of an
eating disorder so I do absolutely
admire olivia strength and dedication to
overcoming her difficulties with food I
actually think that Libya's doing a
great job at fighting coping strategies
that give her a sense of flexibility and
freedom in her approach to food however
I'm just saying and flagging that this
is still not an intuitive and balanced
way to eat I also want to empathize that
my goal with these reviews has always
been a point out responsible content and
problematic content to really help you
make the best decisions about what is
useful and healthy for you to consume
online it is not to tear down other
Creators so I remind you please be kind
in the comments and on her channel as
well let's be empathetic and supportive
at building up people and supporting
their food freedom journeys and on that
note that is all for
today's video I want to give a big thank
you against native for sponsoring this
video and if you liked it be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with any other youtubers that you
want to me to review subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
you